plus républicain la parole est à
monsieur edouard courtial merci monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre je rappelle l'engagement 50
capes du candidat françois hollande
un pacte de confiance et de solidarité
sera conclue entre l'état et les
collectivités locales garantissant le
niveau des dotations à leur niveau
actuel
voilà bien une énième promesse non tenue
les départements se voient appliquer la
double peine
pris en étau entre d'une part la baisse
de la dotation globale de fonctionnement
et d'autre part l'explosion du coût du
rsa ainsi c'est par exemple 20 millions
d'euros qui manqueront à l'oise en 2016
incapable de maîtriser la dérive des
comptes publics
vous laisser aux autres et tout
particulièrement aux départements le
soin d'assumer les efforts budgétaires
nécessaires dans tous les domaines
culture éducation sport insertion
transports les départements dans
d'autres choix que de demander des
efforts considérables à leurs habitants
à leurs agents et à leurs partenaires
notamment les communes et les
associations face à une faillite
annoncée l'assemblée des départements de
france présidée par notre collègue
bussereau vous a demandé dans une
décision prise à l'unanimité des élus de
gauche comme de droite de renationaliser
le rsa ou à minima de compenser les
hausses attendues l'an prochain si les
départements ne peuvent mener à terme
leurs projets si les associations
doivent mettre la clé sous la porte
et si les agents ne sont pas remplacés
ce sera la responsabilité du
gouvernement et non celles des
départements
mais si vous persistez dans ce cynisme
mortifère donner au moins au département
les moyens juridiques de contrôler les
bénéficiaires du rsa et d'exiger d'eux
un travail d'intérêt général comme le
permettrait la proposition de loi que
j'ai déposé votre éternelle rengaine qui
commence par sous le quinquennat
précédent ne marche plus monsieur le
premier ministre
quand allez-vous prendre la mesure de
l'urgence et assumer enfin vos
responsabilités
la parole est à madame la ministre
chargé de la décentralisation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
cortial s'il ya bien un rendez vous
auquel le premier ministre n'a pas
manqué de donner non seulement des
précisions mais des engagements est une
méthode de travail c'est bien celui qui
s'est tenue à matignon entre le premier
ministre lui-même ses ministres et
l'association des départements de france
vous me dites vous nous dites on veut
retourner pas vers le passé je vous
rappelle quand même il faut toujours
avoir en tête que lorsque le rsa a été
créé avec ce mécanisme la 3 milliards 5
étaient pris en charge par les
départements
et nous avons à faire face effectivement
à une augmentation du nombre de rsa et
le débat a été largement ouvert en
disant des choses simples 1
il y aura une attribution de fonds de
secours décision ait déjà été prise
lé département en ont été avertis pour
ceux qui sont le plus en difficulté de
un groupe de travail est vraiment avec
précision a établi le reste à charge
département et doit nous conduire pour
le fin de la fin du mois de mars de
l'année prochaine à une question forte
doiteau remettre le rsa au niveau
national avec tout ce que ça implique y
compris les transferts de ressources et
je vous rappelle que si ce débat a été
ouvert c'est avec courage par le premier
ministre et l'ensemble des ministres
concernés y compris la milice affaires
sociales parce que il faudra en trouver
le financement
et si vous voulez bien participer à ce
qui doit être au sein de notre
république
c'est la vraie question qui doit porter
la solidarité en termes de revenu de
solidarité active bien évidemment mais
aussi en terme d' aide à nos anciens
mais aussi en terme d' aide à nos
personnes en situation de handicap
si on voulait vraiment faire de ce sujet
un sujet républicain du financement de
la solidarité
on éviterait de s'affronter et en
trouver ensemble les bonnes solutions
qui font que la république et solidaire
merci madame ministre pour le groupe
socialiste république